de fizi écouter aujourd'hui c'est les
vacances je suis super content de vous
annoncer qu'on commence un nouveau les
pieds sur un petit juin dès que
j'attends depuis très longtemps il
s'appelle insight se fait par les
créateurs du jeu limbo vous souvenez de
les mots et ben si vous en souvenez pas
démerdez-vous ces partis alors pour
l'histoire on joue un petit garçon qui
se trouve au sein d'une entreprise hyper
bizarre et très autoritaire et voilà je
crois que c'est tout ce qu'il est à
savoir c'est parti maintenant on laisse
la magie opérait alors on est où
oui on tourne haut de la falaise c'est
parti oh là là là là ça me fait déjà pu
faire des mouvements et tout s'est
tellement bien fait alors est ce qu'il
est déjà en train de fuir dans les bois
c'est une question a priori oui un non
pas se mentir on peut sauter c'est
parfait on peut taper peut-être non pas
du tout bon ça va être à base d'énigmes
et de fuite
essentiellement ambiance posée toi même
tu sais c'est quoi les lumières là bas
qu'est ce que c'est que çà ou là à
baladeur ok en fait c'est nous qui
aurons dont l'entreprise [ __ ] qu'est
ce qu'on fait attention à la fois qu'il
me voit ceux contre qui on y va tous
d'eau j'ai cru qu'il recule et si cru
qu'il allait nous écraser
on est en mode discret pourquoi on va
aller dans ce bâtiment on est bête aussi
quand tu fumes le mieux c'est de
d'éviter ce genre d'endroit extrêmement
dangereux bon on verra bien ouh là là
[ __ ] y'a des gens il ya du peuple
cachons nous au [ __ ]
non comment on fait je peux y aller me
verra pas il verra pas ce parti médias
discrétion assurée [ __ ] c'est hyper
jolie hyper hyper jour un frigo
qu'est ce qu'un trio a abandonné fait là
si on est désorienté on peut se mettre
bien ça allait on avance on peut
escalader à ok première énigme je pense
va falloir pousser le frigo comment on
fait pour pousser hockey s'est passé
c'est parce qu'ils étaient de même pas
ils te disent même pas la touche à
l'hébertot avec ton instinct il ya des
chiens [ __ ] ça met la pression et vous
nous sentir à l'oeil mais je sais qu'à
un moment il va nous faire chier c'est
sûr et certain
on avance à mr jo j'ai besoin de
laquelle je pense je la pousse c'est ça
allait on part là dessus donc par là
c'est toi la planche de bois pic à me
faire opérer
bracke blacks on est bon c'est parti
voilà c'est l'énigme hyper simple 1 je
vous rassure on me les a bien vus
compliqué [ __ ] mais pour connaître
pourquoi les mecs cherche déjà ils
savent pas que y'a quelqu'un oui sont
déjà en train de chercher ça je
redemande
oh c'est beau [ __ ] je suis chez les
moutons postillonner allez allez non non
ça je pense qu'on est bon je pense qu'on
est mort oui un bâtard de chien mon gars
je m'étais su en plus en plus c'est
tellement bien calculer il arrive
tellement vite
ok ok en fait faut juste grimper comme
ça après so d'accord taris le chiendent
mexique ou à calme toi
calme-toi acquis qu'ils allaient un trou
supplémentaire on avance on continue
tout droit dans la forêt on s'enfonce un
peu plus là où il ya encore plus de
chien n'est pas bien là on est très très
bien beckham calme bien que non non non
et non route aux fonds non si non c'est
te plaît à terme si motors et duquel ça
a fait que je me cache voilà elle mais
que ces [ __ ] d'assassins qui ne va
pas faire deux fois la même erreur
on va se cacher voilà
c'est comme un conte on va s'arrêter non
c'est me connais bien on avance pour le
mans c'est très correct
c'est très plaisant ils sont garés ça me
plaît pas du tout à ces causes louis ils
descendent
je voudrais faire c'est bon ils m'ont
pas vu simon tahar c'est pire que
faucheurs qui leur sont utiles aux
varois chellah ont fait que de mourir ok
donc cette fois je vais pas me faire
avoir mon gars c'est vraiment le plus
chez vous avez du film d'horreur ce à
quoi le canton potes se prend la branche
qui tombe et tu te retournes et que tu
es et tu devais seconde je l'aide il est
pas je meurs avec qui je meurs pas et
puis ils ont pas honte
il tue un enfant comme ça malheureux qui
comptant les boire de mourir de froid
aucun scrupule
après juste que j'attende ans convoqué
au quai et là je peux repasser plus tard
comment j'étais censé savoir ça il court
vite uv la pression ok on a réussi il
tient [ __ ] mais c'est quoi ce délire
pourquoi il nous traquent comme ça et
pourquoi
merde allez on a tenté la branche bon il
ya des chiens merde ouais on a feinté la
branche mais mort douloureuse des
rockets cette fois les chefs vous
m'aurez pas on va pas chanter la branche
voilà on avance bien comme il faut dans
la sauter au dernier moment
ok [ __ ] il ya c'est une oeuvre d'art
mon gars je suppose il faut que j'aille
prendre de l'air et repartir pour partir
vite vite on est bien et nous voit pas
on est extrêmement bien on va pas se
mentir
[ __ ] ils sont terrifiés c'est
incroyable comme c'est bien calculé pour
te mettre la pression de ouf
mais pour que tu arrive quand même à
t'en sortir par les chiens et le chien
est un millimètre de ta jambe avant tout
sauf que ça met beaucoup la pression
auprès des cochons égorgé ici [ __ ]
c'est quoi c'est de ce monde légal c'est
quoi ce délire qui s'y font là ils
traquent les humains et les cochons
hausse et de la forêt aucun scrupule
pour ces hommes ça vous plaît cette
ambiance poser un peu ça me plaît
beaucoup
voilà mes puis la taille des fougères si
tu veux un homme adulte un basketteur on
le voit pas dans ces fous gèrent donc
nous dionne notre petit m on est plutôt
tranquille
il ya des chiens et un brin de chien un
chat qui couine non pas qu'elle ait
gardé une sorte de paranoïa générale
télé bien ces petits poussins avec moi
je vous surfez et il me suis vraiment en
plus ça c'est trop mignon troqué à un
bâtiment le premier bâtiment qu'on voit
déjà comme une bonne nouvelle
oui c'est une sorte de ferme c'est ça sa
pensée en abattoir apparemment prisées
de 0,8 à ces lignes c'est mignon mais un
peu chelou qu'avec les l'appui de cochon
décédé à côté
oui c'est l'heure du bâtiment justement
au nom liche j'ai entendu un chien non
là vous aider vous allez dire vous allez
prendre pour un [ __ ] de parano je vous
jure jean trop bien faire pour être
honnête
qu'est ce que c'est que ça un levier
apparemment rien du tout on va voir ce
qu'on peut faire
voilà en tout cas réparer c'est pas ça
ah bah voilà c'est très bien ça donc on
a vu la tour 2 2 dimanche
ok c'est en route du coup logiquement
les leviers devrait maintenant marché du
thym première année qui me passait hall
a marqué durant plus cette énigme à ok
ça envoie de l'air et ça va faire tomber
le truc là où d'accord
mais un truc pas ça je peux toujours pas
vexer les yeux quand vous faire l'un on
va aller voir dehors avant de rire d'or
c'est pas possible
alors c'est le pousse à se tourner y'a
rien de avec sûr je pense à rien ils me
suivent en dedans d'accord par là dessus
comment ils peuvent m'aider ce qui te
pousse un autre c'est ça ça fait genre
ok en fait ça aspire ici non non je
crois que j'ai compris c'est une [ __ ]
broyeuse ça aboie et les poussins c'est
envoyer leur gré sur la caisse va la
faire tomber
et c'est au rythme et au non dit là on
va donc voir si aujourd'hui ça commence
comme ça alors s il reste plein c'est
bon on en fait c'est juste envoyer ces
zapa broyer [ __ ] j'ai eu peur
adieu mais pour ça merci pour tout je
l'emmène carte postale ok alors on va
sauter assez assez une stricte version
ultra gore au dessous de la foi dans un
tas de porc décédé bien sûr puisqu'elle
a dit ou pas n'ont pas retiré le chariot
rempli de porc décédé c'est ça voilà
c'est bien ses propres tout ça très très
propre aller allons-y [ __ ] c'est à
quoi ils ont donné une dimension
tellement glauque
c'est cent fois de plus glauque que
limbo quoi simple qui était déjà quand
même un peu glauque en vrai tant qu'il
ya plus les hommes avec les fusils
franchement on est bien franchement un
avant on n'était vraiment pas bien là ça
va au pirée quoi il ya un port qui s'il
peut nous faire le corps en vie sont
tous décédés un pas de porte à garder
sont tous morts c'est terrible terrible
o o le poison violent et ça fera aux
corridas a maintenant mission glauque
l'arep thalys points 43 tours ont tué
d'abord je te ramène est révolution de
porcs à ok faut qu'il passe la porte en
la chargeant réouvre il nous a mis dans
le port
oh [ __ ] style et vite c'était limite
limite et je pars pas les jeux de
société exemple au t3 cemex est trop
bien fait et du coup grâce à lui on peut
escalader parce qu'il est épuisé
ah non qu'est ce que je dois faire faut
tirer le port pour lui ce cas là dessus
non mais ya forcément un truc à faire
mais non mais pourquoi tu fais ça
mais pourquoi tu fais ça je lui ai
arraché ça que tu as et quarantaine
queue de cochon ça si je suis en train
de ramener ce port ag devrait accéder à
la lampe pour allumer c'est ça je pense
que c'est ça ok c'est ça
ward
je contrôle les mecs de derrière mes
mecs mais c'est génial comme je soulève
ça c'est dur ok faudrait que eux
s'avancent hockey et la choulette
ailleurs mais cloud sort de nulle part
d'accord mais va pouvoir aider l'autre
voilà mes mecs mais c'est quoi ce délire
c'est quoi cet univers là je la tire et
ça ça faut le tirer à temps mais c'est
claude bouffe ça mais qui permet à
bassam à créer un chemin de mon côté
donc comment je lâche ça ok c'est bon
merci le port je te sert la pâte et je
m'en vais c'est à la fois fascinant et à
la fois extrêmement effrayée
c'est très bizarre allez on y va en
avance sur quoi on va tomber mouillé
c'est début du jeu vous trouve déjà sur
sa [ __ ] qu'est ce que ça va être à la
fin et s'est levé on sort au jeu rnd
soleil mais ce travail qu'ils ont fait
sur les lumières surtout celui design
c'est exceptionnel c'est de toute beauté
on se retrouve dans une sorte de
prairies entre les égouts les bâtiments
et toute chose bienvenue au la [ __ ]
ils font la queue ils font la queue pour
être contrôlé par un mec qui a un casque
est pendu par le casque finalement
pourquoi ils font ça ça leur sert à quoi
mais les gens ont l'air de faire la
queue pour être manipulée pour peut-être
obtenir quelque chose derrière je sais
pas allez on sort déjà des théories un
peu foireuse à savoir le pousser dans le
tir et à mon avis
ouais ça l'aurait une porte quelque
chose un bâtiment
ça fait quoi m'expliquer ce que ça fait
à affaler poussé par dont celle inverse
ok en fait fallu pousser pour la chaîne
décembre moi je les fais monter voilà on
est bien alors on montre où ça va nous
mener cette histoire un quelque chose
bloque on va découvrir après les ports
décédées après le petit chasse aux
produits par le casque quand je fais ch
provo la fenêtre je peux à lever hop
allons nous en hockey alors comment
faire tomber cette caisse là où je dois
être plus loin x revient en arrière je
pense
ouais c'est ça le truc faut aller par là
voilà ici on a eu un petit leulier ont
fait lever ça on re saute on remonte et
là qu'est ce qu'on fait ah on saute sur
sa claque puis on saute sur un mais
c'est pas possible je suis débile ça je
peux le pousser en fait beau la juste à
faire ça je totalement débile ok ok
c'est parti on va pousser la caisse
hockey des limites limite on va
redescendre tout en bas et je pense que
de cette hauteur là le trou logiquement
ne va pas nous tuer non il nous a juste
pété les deux jambes on est bien ensuite
il ya une grille par laquelle on va
sûrement devoir passer hop tout à fait
et on arrive à olemps qui sait que ça
c'est le truc qui alimente le casque et
qui permet de contrôler les gens ont
pensé je sais pas hop là
on a bien cassé bah écoutez les amis je
crois que c'était un très bon premier
épisode j'adorais cette ambiance posée
ce jeu magnifique
n'hésitez pas à lui mais ça vous a plu
et si vous vouliez vous ici un petit
l'espé comme ça sur un jeu cool en mode
ambiance posée et a misé à chaque fois
des besoins y aura un lien comme ça et
qui dirigera vers l'épisode suivant si
les sorties actuellement c'est pas
encore le cas on se trouve samedi pour
le deuxième épisode j'ai à djabou et
j'ai hâte de franchir cette petite rap
et de voir ce qui avait de l'autre côté
du trou 1 à samedi quatre pis